bitcoin specifically a lot of these
institutions are rumored to want to get
access to it what about ethereum and
solana are you seeing demand for those
as well
sure
but look
ultimately it comes down to liquid asset
classes you know i'm in foreign exchange
and eurodollar is the the biggest traded
asset class um biggest credit instrument
so any given day eurodollar is going to
make up 30
of all the fx trading that's just it so
bitcoin today is going to make up
40 50
so solana yes it's coming ethereum yes
it's coming but the most liquidity still
gravitates to um to the number one in
the asset class so it's up i'd say to
the
the founders the engineers behind the
other coins you've got to keep proving
that point
right the argument is oh bitcoin for
payments ethereum for utility okay well
you gotta start showing us the utility
and the same with solana
right if you want that to trade more if
you want that price to go up if you want
to have more liquidity you've got to
keep proving the utility of those coins
yeah and you don't think bitcoin has to
prove that
i think it's proven
for me you know the more you look at it
the more you research it bitcoin's
proven
well it's been around what 13 14 years
now i don't know how long satoshi
thought about it before he created it
it's proven and it's been through the
peaks and troughs
you know you know i said it i've said it
before look at uh
you know march 21 was march 20 the start
of the pandemic
every asset class got sold off
oil traded below zero bitcoin chart said
it was going to zero it didn't
right it found a level
and it bounced back
and it traded what 64 000 the end of
last year now trading 46 000. this is
now a robust asset so i don't think it's
got anything anything left to prove and
um
you know you're not seeing many
level one protocol breaches right with
this asset i'm i'm as comfortable
holding that
as i am holding fang stocks
or holding gold in my portfolio and i
think that's why
it will go from strength to strength and
the others still have a lot waterproof
hey you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time